داخليا وطني ودولي ايضا
بالاضافه الى الحوامات والطائرات 76 طائره
126 حوامه
بالاضافه الى عشرات
البواخر والعديد من
الاليات
الاخرى وبعد مرور ساعه طويله على
ارتداديه الى الان ما زالت هنالك فرق
البحث والانقاذ يقومون
بانقاذ احياء وناجين من مباني التي
تحطمت
بالاضافه الى القيام بانشاء مطابخ متنقله
ميدانيه ويقومون بتوزيع
ثلاث وجبات ساخنه
يوميا بالاضافه الى مياه الشرب والعديد من
الخدمات الاخرى
قمنا بالتلقي
طلبات من مئه
الدوله بين فريقين للبحث والانقاذ الى
المساعدات
دوله قدمه اربعه دول انتهوا
عادوا الى ادوالهم بالاضافه الى ان هنالك
مئات الافراك ما زالوا موجودين هذه اول
مره تحدث هذه الارقام الكبيره
بمشاركه الفرق الدوليه بهذه
الكارثه التي تعرضنا لها كان هنالك
اتصالات لنا مع عشرات القدم والزعماء ما
بين رئيس
الدولارات كما قمنا باستقبال الامير
القطري
وجميع المسؤولين
انسانيه
هذا بالاضافه الى استقبالنا للمساعدات من
اكثر من سبعا وستين دوله من اسيا الى
افريقيا الى امريكا الى اوروبا جميع الدول
الصديقه
والشعوب
الشقيقه قاموا بارسال هذه المساعدات الى
جمهوريه التركيه جميع هذه الدول الشقيقه
وحليفه اشكر الدول
والشعوب باسمي وباسم شعبي الى تعازيم
الحاره بالاضافه الى مساعدتهم الماديه
والعينيه السيدات الصدر
الاعزاء ما زال الجميع الفرق تعمل سنقوم
ببذئ قصار جهودنا من اجل الوصول الى اخر
حي ومن ثم ازاله
انقض والقيم بواجباتنا وامامنا المقاطعه
على عاتقنا كما نقوم ايضا بمهامنا
وواجباتنا الانسانيه من اجل دفن جميع
الضحايا والتسليم
الجثث الى ذويهم نبذ القصار جودنا من اجل
بالمرحله الثانيه من اجل اعاده الاعماري
والبناء لمنازل والوحدات السكنيه بالاضافه
الى مكان العمل كما ستقوم وحده
وحدات سكنيه
العامه هي تابعه لحكومه
تقوم هذه المؤسسه ببناء جميع المباني
والشقق السكنيه التي تراعي شروط بناءها
وفقها او المقاومه
الزلازل وبالتالي سنقوم بتسليم جميع
المواطنين الذين تضرروا مباني مقاومه
الزلازل خلال عاما واحد فقط
كما تعلمون كان هنالك العديد من المباني
كانت قد بنيت قبل قانون الذي تم اصداره
بعد زلزال عام 1999 نحن نعلم جيدا بانها
الرسائل
ورسائل لنا وبالتالي سنكون دقيقين
وحساسينا في بناء المباني الجديده وفق
شروط الصادره من الوسارات لمقاومه الزلازل
اذهب بالاضافه باننا قمنا باعطاء الاوامر
والتعليمات التي لا من اللازمه من اجل
اعاده البناء وتسليمها الى اصحابها
الحقيقيين سنقوم بالعمل بشكل مباشر
اعتبارا من شهر اذار مارس نقوم
بشكل مباشر بثلاثين
بناء هذا
بالاضافه نحن نعيد الجميع باننا خلال فتره
قصيره نقوم ببناء في جميع الولايات بما
ننهيه خلال عام واحدا لجميع المباني لتكون
هذه المباني امنه
ومقاومه للزلزال وتسليمها الى اصحابها
طبعا خلال هذا
العامه زالت هنالك نصب
لمخيمات بالاضافه الى تقديم الايجار لكل
اصحابي البيوت الذين يقومون الذين يريدون
الاقامه في بيوتين جائزه نحن عملنا خططنا
بشكل كامل من اجل تقديم الخدمات خلال عام
كما
مواطنين الصبر لمده عام فقط كما نعد
الجميع بتقديم دعم الكامل لكل من يريد
الاقامه في اي ولاده يريد بها بتقديم
الدعم المادي لنقل امتعته كما كنا في
زلازل وان ملاطيا العجز بينجو وغيرها من
الولايات بالاضافه الى الولايات التي
تعرضت للشيول غراس وقسم الاضافه الى
انطاليا وبولا التي تعرضت للحرائق كما كنا
خلال فتره قصيره جدا
بوصولي الى هذه المناطق السابقه التي
تتعرضت او التي تعرضت للكوارث الطبيعيه
وقمنا بتسليم جميع المباني والوحدات
السكنيه اليها خلال عامة
تجانبه بشكل
سنقوم ايضا بتسليمي الوحدات السكنيه
واماكن العمل خلال عام واحد لجميع
المتضرين في الولايات
عشره
المواطنين الذين تعرضوا لهذه الكارثه
ليعلم باننا الى جانبهم وسنعمل ليلا
ونهارا دون
ملل من اجل التصدي والوصول الى جميع
مواطنين ومن اجل اعادتهم الى الحياه
الكريمه البارحه كنت في زياره الى مستشفى
تشام ساكورا وكنت في زياره لجميع
المنتظرين ومنكوبين من امهات واطفال وجميع
العائلات
الذين كانوا يتطلقون علاج في تلك المستشفى
هنالك بعض المنكوبي ومتضررين
[موسيقى]
من اجل الاقامه الى جانب اقاربهم في ولايه
اسطنبول الى تلاقيهم
علاج بشكل مجاني في مستشفى تشام ساكورا
هذا بالاضافه الى استقبال العديد من
المستشفيات التابعه لوزاره
الصحابي الاشراف الكامل على جميع
المنكوبين والمتدرين والذين يطلقون العلاج
في جميع المستشفيات في مدينه اسطنبول هذا
بالاضافه باننا سنقوم بتقديم
خمسه عشر الفين في خمسه عشر الف ليره
تركيه الى جميع العائلات المنكوبه
بالاضافه الى
تقديمي 5000 لكل عائله تريد ان تنقل
امتعتها
الى جميع الولايات وتقديمي دعم
المحروقات
الى ذوي المركبات والاليات الذين يريدون
النقل الممتعتهم عبر الياتهم الخاصه
كما اننا سنقوم بتقديم الدعم عبر اجراء
تقييمات كامله في الاونه المقبله
نحن كحكومه وكشعب لن نترك اي مواطن
تضرر وتعرض لهذه كارثه الطبيعيه دون
الوصول اليه وتقديم الدعم الكامل
اعطينا اوامرنا وتعلمتنا الكامله لجميع
الوزارات والمديريات العامه
التابعه لها
كما ستقوموا جميع الوزارات
ومديريات ايضا
توجيهي نسبه كبيره من ارباحها الى الان
قرابه 50 مليار ليله ليره تركيه حتى الان
سنقوم بتخصيصها
والمتضرين في هذا في هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه
هذا بالاضافه سنقوم بتقديم الدعم الكامل
لجميع الحرفيين الصناعي واماكن العمل
كتقديمها كقروض لكل من يريد
افتتاح اماكن عمله مره اخرى
الوصول الى جميع المعامل والمصانع لاعاده
الحياه التجاريه
والصناعيه في جميع هذه الولايات كما يستعد
الجميع
باننا سنبذل قصارى جهودنا ايضا من اجل
تقديم الدعم
الكامل في مجال المصارف والبنوك وتاجيل
الديون
وقروت هذا بالاضافه
سيصل عدد المستفيدين من هذه قروض تاجيل
الى اكثر من
60000 مواطن هذا بالاضافه الى
مليارات
الليرات التركيه
الدعم يوم غد
تكون جميع قنوات التلفزه في اذربيجان وفي
شمال
قبرص التركيه سنكون هنالك اشتراك
بمشاركه مع جميع الوزارات
القيام
بحمله لحمله التبرع
للمتدرين يشارك فيها جميع الوزارات
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
اكثر من
مليون ليره تركيه حتى الان بلغ حجم
التبرعات من
الوزارات
واصحاب الاعمال الخيره والمتطوعين والذين
يريدون المشاركه في هذه
في هذه حمليها حملات التبرع
السيدات الساده
الاعزاءنا
والنائبي بالاضافه الى جميع الوزاره
بالاضافه الى جميع الوزارات كنا مشاركين
في عمليات التنسيق الكامل من اجل الوصول
الى المواطنين
كما تعلمون زلزلان كبيران بالاضافه الى
شروط الشروط الجويه
الصعبه نبذ القصاره جهودنا من اجل اعاده
الحياه الى ما كانت عليها كما قمنا ايضا
بالتخصيص قرابه 800 مليون
بناء عاما بالاضافه الى وحدات السكن
الطلابيه
الى الان تم استقبال اكثر من مليون ونصف
مليون في هذه الوحدات والمباني العامه
بالاضافه الى نصب مخيمات
الجاهزه وتوزيع
البطانيات والمساعدات كما كان هنالك ايضا
عشر منازل جاهزه توجهت من قطر الى
الولايات المنكوبه
عشره الاف منزل جاهز
الذي قام بعد بعد استخدامها
التي كانت مهيئه باحدث
الظروف
والشروط
العالميه من اجل استضافه كاس العام العالم
في عام 2022 في قطر الان تم وضعها في
الابواخر وستتوجه خلاده خلال ساعات الى
الولايات المنكوبه هذا بالاضافه
جميع حملات التبرع الالبسه والاغذيه وجميع
المستلزمات والاحتياجات اللازمه لجميع
المنكوبين مازالت مستمره عبر الجوي والبري
والبحر
الاساطير تقوم
بتقديمها وحملها
للوصول الى مناطق الزلزال كما انه هنالك
بعض الولايات
ممن فتحت فنادقها
مواطنين وضعنا جميع امكانيات وطاقتي
الجمهوريه التركيه
تحت خدمته الان منكوبين هذا بالاضافه قمنا
بفتح وحدات
الطلاب السكنيه الجامعيه ايضا دوله
الطلاب الجامعيين وفتحيه امام جميع
المنكوبين
ومتضررين ليتم كان
هنالك الاف عاملين في الوزارات
والمديريات
بالاضافه الى المتطوعين ما زالوا يعملون
بنفس المعنويات
العشرين من شبهات ستكون جميع المدارس
والجامعات في الوالي الولايات غير
المتضرره بفتح
ابوابها
بالاضافه سيكون التعليم الجامعي عن بعد في
الولايات متضرره
سنقوم باضافه ولايه العزيز ولايه حاديه
عشره
ستكون هنالك هيئات تقوم
الدراسه والتمرين والفحص الكامل لجميع
المدارس
هل هي صالحه من اجل اعاده الطلاب اليها او
لا كما سنقوم ايضا بنقل الطلاب والمدارس
الى الولايات
المجاوره من اجل اكمال مدارسهم تقوم جميع
جميع الوزارات والقوات المسلحه التركيه
والقوات الامن الداخلي وقوات غفرت سواحل
وجميع
موظفين في
بلديات تبنوا هذه المهمه والواجب الاسلامي
ثلاثه وسبعين الف من القوات المسلحه اكثر
من 60 الف من الجندرمه يقومون بتقديم
الخدمات لمده
24 ساعه على مد
ملحمه وطنيه بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه بمشاركه
جميع الوزارات
ومتبرعين
المتطوعين القوات المسلحه البريه والبحريه
يبذلون قصارى جودهم ايضا من اجل المشاركه
في ازاله الانقاض وتقديم المساعده ونقل
المنكوبين
ومتدرين اكثر من 28
الف جندي تابعون للقوات المسلحه التركيه
ماذا لو موجودون ويبذرون قصار جودي
ويعملون ليلا ونهارا من اجل تقديمه
المساعده الى الفرق المختصه هذا
بالاضافه قامت وزاره الصحابه بتوجيه اكثر
من
1250 سياره
وحوامته
اسعاف هذا بالاضافه الى
انشائي المستشفيات الميدانيه
المتنقله من اجل تقديم الدعم
الى هذه
الاماكن كما نشكر جميع
العاملين في مناجم المعادن الذين جاؤوا من
الولايات الاخرى كانوا جبارين
بحفر وفتح الانفاق والمشاركه
الكامله مع جميع الفرق المختصه للبحث
وانقاذ من اجل المشاركه في انقاذ
ناجينا واخراجهم من البنايات المتضرره
كما ستقوم ايضا جميع منظمات المجتمع
المدني ووزاره
العائله بتكفل